that don't have a lot of regrets in life  but there's a there's a um  there's a saying No Regrets and I've  never understood it because I do have  regrets and one is when we were doing  our show at TBS you contacted me and I I  had no idea you were serious you said  I'd like to do the upholstery  I'd like to make you your talk show  couch and I was like that's so hilarious  man that's great and then later on  you're like no no I was serious I would  have made your you would have made that  and I I felt like such a such a lost  opportunity to have a talk show where  Jack White made my talk show couch I'm  looking at four upholstered chairs right  now it's not too late that's true yeah  we should put you to work